savez-vous qui se cache derrière la
marque auchan à l'origine une famille
celle des mulliez et plus précisément un
homme gérard mulliez depuis la création
de champs 1961 à roubaix le chef
d'entreprise se fait rare sur les
plateaux de télévision
il s'en explique en 1986 vingt-cinq ans
après la création du groupe
moi je ne sais pas parler à la
télévision c'est la première fois que je
le fais ici et je ne sais pas organiser
des grands shows et par contre je sais
créer des entreprises et c'est à soi et
que je me suis attaché depuis 25 ans
gérard mulliez est une figure
emblématique du monde de la grande
distribution
il faut dire que sa réussite il la doit
à une stratégie bien ficelée
mettez vos le prix au printemps ont été
voir le prix dans d'autres magasins et
on a vraiment cassé le prix des lames de
rasoir et quinze jours trois semaines
après je rencontre mon cousin qui me dit
tu sais j'ai dit à ma femme qu'elle
devait faire ses courses chez toi parce
que tu es moins cher je dis oui je suis
moins cher pourquoi
et bien parce que tu es lame de rasoir
125 % moins cher qu'au printemps dans
les années 90 le dirigeant de chant se
tient toujours autant à l'écart des
caméras
gérard mulliez un homme discret mais qui
tient à rappeler d'où il vient en 1993
interviewé lors de l'émission les 4
vérités sur france 2 il évoque l'esprit
familial de son entreprise
moi je suis un raté de l'éducation
nationale mon directeur général et a
raté aussi l'éducation nationale les
premiers cadres avec qui j'ai des
marettes et des gens qui avaient été
exclus du textile et nous avons démarré
avec des jeunes qui n'étaient pas
diplômé et nous avons fait un groupe
aujourd'hui qui emploie de l'ordre de 60
mille personnes en 2006 gérard mulliez
prend sa retraite à 75 ans il cède sa
place de numéro un du groupe auchan à
son petit neveu vianney mulliez
mais il n'est jamais loin du monde des
affaires en 2009 invité à un forum
économique à lille il fait l'une de ses
dernières apparitions à la télévision
avec toujours le même mot d'ordre la
discrétion
je ne vois pas bien l'intérêt d'aller
inspiré mes concurrents de manière trop
proche donc j'aime mieux qu'on soit
discret qu'un disque aujourd'hui
edgar bonté le nouveau patron d'auchan
gérard mulliez reste lui adhérents de
l'afm l'association familiale mulliez
composé de 700 membres
cet empire familial est à la tête d'une
quinzaine de marques dont kiabi
boulanger ou encore leroy merlin
[Musique]